esta misión de la televisión Estatal
iraní Presenta una pareja francesa como
dos agentes secretos la pareja
identificada como cecilcoler y su
compañero Jack para ahí habla en francés
la mujer dice ser un agente de
inteligencia operativa de la dirección
general de seguridad exterior afirma que
están allí para derrocar al régimen
iraní y presionar al gobierno para el
ministro de asuntos exteriores francés
se trata de un claro caso de coacción
París ha negado firmemente las
declaraciones realizadas en el video la
pareja fue detenida al pasado mes de
mayo en Irán antes de ser acusada de
conspirar contra la seguridad del Estado
según el secretario general del
sindicato fossufrea para el que trabaja
cecilcolea tanto ella como el señor
parry habían ido de viaje a Irán durante
las vacaciones de Semana Santa la
transmisión ha suscitado otros
interrogantes anteriormente Teherán ya
utilizado a ciudadanos extranjeros o
binacionales como Rehenes para obtener
concesiones de potencias extranjeras
también se produce en el contexto de una
manifestaciones en Irán desencadenada
por la muerte de maxada Mini tras su
detención en septiembre por la llamada
policía de la moral
mientras Francia y la Unión Europea
amenazan con sanciones Por su forma de
reprimir la revuelta de las mujeres
iraníes cuando el régimen teocrático de
Irán se ve amenazado recurre a este tipo
de métodos para evitar las sanciones se
trata de la política de Rehenes que Irán
ha puesto en marcha para evitar las
sanciones de la Unión Europea en el
contexto de la represión de las
protestas por los derechos de las
mujeres en el país
la investigadora Franco iraníbab del K
fue detenida en junio de 2019 y
condenada 5 años de prisión por atentar
contra la seguridad nacional mientras
que Benja Ayer fue detenido en mayo de
2020 y condenado a 8 años y ocho meses
de prisión por presuntos espionaje